[Applaudissements]
et moi je vois là moi je vous aime
beaucoup voilà je voulais aussi j'ai
envie des pyrénées oui bah écoutez mais
nike sont des systèmes bien merci
beaucoup c'est une vraie sont ils
traités plus ont été gentils acheter
voilà c'était mon petit quart d'heure
bisous mais les gars on m'avait dit ça
tu es beau tu es gentil et je t'aime
bien faire avec ce livre est la dernière
personne qui m'a dit ça c'était ma mère
oui eh ben non c'est pas ta mère et ton
père à bon chat bon chien non la mort à
bord
j'ai peut être jamais animaux donc tout
va bien qui se met sur les rangs mais
bien même les pois les animaux et leur
as c'est votre sim jean michel maire
rêve passé dont les poils
ah ouais les gars van den je peux le
laisser pousser à vous inquiéter pas de
si lui peut tout faire ainsi les chaux
vive est capable de tout eve angeli est
là alors content de l'avoir très très
très moi aussi j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup cette personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors un mauvais ouvriers a toujours un
mauvais oublier a toujours un mauvais
ouvriers a toujours un bon marteau